welcome back to the david pakman show i
am faring cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and
don't forget you can find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the ring of fire
and youtube.com slash fahren balanced
we had a lot of movement over this past
weekend
on the infrastructure bill the slim down
infrastructure bill we still of course
have reconciliation on the other part
which
unfortunately not going so well but
let's talk about what is kind of
going well at this point senate did
vote to move forward on infrastructure
negotiations
infrastructure debate really good like i
said
positive developments it looks like you
are getting some republicans
who are starting to come around to this
obviously whatever happens in the senate
this thing
still has to go through the house of
representatives
where it's going to go through even more
changes so far from over at this point
but we are seeing forward
progress but there's somebody who's not
happy about forward progress somebody
who has been shouting for two weeks now
that forward progress is a bad thing and
you guessed it ladies and gentlemen that
person is none other
than former president donald j
trump trump issued a warning
to republicans over the weekend he said
joe biden's infrastructure bill is a
disgrace
will be very hard for me to endorse
anyone foolish enough to vote in favor
of this deal
you know what i love about that
statement it's such a small statement
okay
it's so tiny it's just a little sentence
two sentences i guess technically
but uh it says so much
about american politics today not just
about trump not just about the
republican party but it says so much
about politics
so i have to break this statement down
again this tiny little statement i'm
breaking it down
three different ways the first one
is take off partisan blinders get rid of
hatred for trump
get rid of support for infrastructure
all of that let's just look at this
as political strategy because what i'm
going to say here might shock you
from a strategy standpoint
trump is right i know i know uh
it's weird to even say it but
he's right what's the republicans best
chance to win in the 2022 midterms
showing the public that the democrats
couldn't get anything done
showing the public that all these lofty
goals of the democratic party
fell flat and of course by doing that
they're going to omit the part where
they're the ones who made it all fail
that's how the talking point works
but mitch mcconnell was very clear a
couple months ago when he said on camera
we've got to make sure that they can't
move forward on their agenda because
mcconnell knows the same thing
they've got to make a pitch to voters
because so far all their attacks on
biden
have failed that's another important
thing to remember folks
all their attacks have failed so far
because they don't have anything real
to attack him on so if they give him
this infrastructure package that is a
big win for the democratic party
not as big as it should have been
certainly not as big as they were asking
for in the plan
but if the democrats produce if the
democrats go to the public and say we
got you this
because remember it's not just an
infrastructure plan folks it is a jobs
plan
that is widely supported by members of
both parties out there in america
so again this is only looking at this
through
nonpartisan eyes trump saying
do not support this that is
what the republicans would be doing
except of course
the other side of that strategy and this
is where trump is totally wrong on it
as i just mentioned majority of
republicans out there support this
heck a majority of republicans even
support raising taxes
on the wealthy and corporations to pay
for it they supported it before it was
even cut down to 1.2 trillion they liked
it when it was three and a half trillion
they want the plan so they would be less
likely in turn
based on that to believe republican
talking points
that democrats were unable to deliver
because they're clearly paying at least
somewhat attention to this issue
and that's another positive development
they know who's holding this thing up
they know that they want it and they
know that republicans and to a degree
mansion and cinema don't want them to
have it
so that's why republicans are stuck
between the rock and a hard place here
on terms of strategy
they want to get democrats to lose
but they can't have their voters who
support this bill
know that they were the ones who kept it
from making it to them
so i think at this point some of them
clearly not all of them but i do think
some of them
have looked at this and said you know
what the best path forward for us
is probably to let this thing happen
at least hey maybe then if there are
some positive developments out of it
once it passes
i can go back to my constituents and
tell them i supported this thing i did
this for you
i did this for you so that could likely
be the strategy that these people take
moving forward and
of course there's also the third part
and that is who cares if trump withholds
his endorsement
there was a study that came out last
week and i actually uh
spoke about this on my other channels
because it's a phenomenal study i love
it
they looked at races where donald trump
endorsed a candidate
versus races where donald trump did not
endorse a candidate
and the political scientists who looked
at all of these endorsements and
all of the outcomes came to a
statistical conclusion
that a donald trump endorsement
makes you two and a half percent less
likely to win your race
candidates who received the trump
endorsement again
two and a half percent not two and a
half times two and a half percent
less likely to win so it's a very very
tiny tiny
disadvantage but it's a disadvantage
nonetheless
and the report also did mention that
yeah when trump endorses a candidate
they end up raising a ton more money but
you know who else does
their opponent every time trump comes
out and endorses somebody they raise
more money
but so does their opponent they also
found that
voter turnout actually does increase in
races where donald trump endorses a
candidate
but again in most instances it benefits
the opponent
not the person trump endorsed so trump
wants to be the king maker he's out
there pretending to be the king maker
he's threatening them
trying to scare them into submission
saying i'm not going to endorse you if
you don't do this and republicans need
to respond with
respond with uh good like please don't
endorse me in fact could you endorse my
primary opponent
because i really want to win this
election
and your endorsement at this point is
effectively a kiss of death
you're not helping candidates you're
hurting them you're
literally making things more difficult
for
them so don't come out there acting like
i'm gonna withhold my endorsement don't
threaten us with a good time man
we've seen the numbers we know what the
data looks like we know that your
endorsement
doesn't change people's minds
and when it does it changes them in
favor of the other
candidate so again republicans you're
not
actually stuck between the rock and the
hard place here
you've got a pretty easy out vote in
favor of the infrastructure package go
back to your constituents tell them that
you delivered it for them
and give donald donald trump the finger
on the way out the door
because trust me you don't want his
endorsement
unless of course you're looking forward
to early retirement that would really be
the only
thing that would work in your favor at
that point